the talk of the town of the minute is
homeboy tinder swindler
have you watched the team yeah i watched
it i watched it the movie last week also
yeah what's your last week i haven't
actually watched that i've heard i've
had all the cliff notes oh okay i
haven't actually watched this it's like
two hours long i'm glad you've watched
it it's um it's a good show it's
actually it's actually a good watch to
be fair
um but yeah what'd you just say yeah
what did you want to see so um anyone
who whoever doesn't know
tinder swindler you can fit in the bits
that i i i get wrong yeah tinder
swindler so is a brother from israel no
yes originally yes yeah who would
basically jump on tinder and pretend to
be the son of a diamond dealer or
whatever
like a billionaire yeah samuel aviv yeah
yeah and what he would do is
pretend that he would use the real story
of the diamond dealer situation to
basically say that his assets are
frozen or whatever but he's still got
like these private jets and he's still
got all these things so basically he's
creating a vision that he's actually
rich as [ __ ]
and then he'll make an excuse
for his frozen assets for these yachts
to send him money
and then he would spend that money on
another ticket to convince her to send
him money yeah
mad
mad mad
but one thing and obviously everyone's
kicking up a fuss about it and he got
caught slipping because
one of the chicks heard about him
and then took his gums to sell in it
yeah yeah because he needed some quick
cash so she said she was a she was a
buyer or a seller or something sorry
like that i can't remember yeah and she
started and she just kept the p mm-hmm
then she was supposed to grants and
grants to make up the money that she
already sent him yeah gang gang for her
um thing is though this is my this is
the way i think about it
i don't know why everyone's vex
explain he's just any city boy
nice
he's any c boy he's any is any summer
boy yeah and like
he's just the male version of what a lot
of people do anyway that don't happen to
be male mm-hmm do you know what i mean
let's just let's cut through the cheddar
sprig a little sugar yeah yeah like he's
not
mass he's clearly far more elaborate
yeah of course but the in terms of what
he's actually doing
like
he's just finding reasons to have
yeah send him money
he lives an elaborate lifestyle mum um
it's it's also a brave very obviously
very very very very brave thing to do i
just don't understand how
he can do it
let's say he swindled one yet for like
10 bags or whatever i needed my enemies
are after me give me ten bags my enemies
bro
first of all he loves that lie there's
no human being that can message me
saying i need x amount of money because
my enemies are after me
if you don't think i'm asking you the
[ __ ] are your enemies fam you need to
you need to either tell me who your
enemies are
or this conversation is ending because i
don't understand how you think i could
just
enemy thank you who uses that
terminology no one asked him questions
they just he just kept saying enemies
enemies enemies what does that mean to
me
are they my enemies too
do you know if i run either are they our
enemies our enemies
are these enemies
but no one questioned it they just sent
him the p
man said to one chick no take out a loan
take take out a loan sell your car try
and sell your house babe please hurry up
fast my enemies are after me
i couldn't understand brother
but he does it so well because
he does it so well because he doesn't
tell them anything of that until a month
in he sucks you in yeah he takes you to
breakfast in brussels he will [ __ ]
take you for lunch in luxembourg or
whatever same day
also he'll be roping let's go here let's
go oh okay for a month or whatever okay
so for that first month he sucks you in
his assets aren't frozen he's asking
he's doing what he wants i don't know i
don't know how he's patting that p but
he's probably gotten p that's because
yeah because that's what he's doing he's
using the p from the last from the last
this new thing exactly it doesn't seem
lucrative though because where's what's
the turnover it's it's not lucrative
what's the roi
i mean because how much of this ten bags
from chick one are we spending on chick
two bro loads low but i think within
this within the same breath he's got
like a couple other things
for that month as well yeah so he's got
like the main source source a
and he's got like b c and d to pattern
this new thing that this new girlfriend
is trying to splurge all summer of so
there was a you say you've not seen it
but there was a time where he's already
patented two things and he's already
scammed them yeah kind of clocked
already yeah they're trying to get their
p back yeah man's gone on holiday with a
next russian ting
the whole summer
bags upon bags upon bags upon bags and
while he's doing that he's messaging
these other yo these other hoes babes i
need 10k cash my enemies are after me
please while is in no boo fam doing up
you see him and his bouncer just like
this yats everywhere everywhere
everywhere he's sending voice notes baby
we'll be over soon we just penned the
deal this that and the other the money's
cleared for my end you should be
receiving in a couple days this time the
other and he will gas them he will send
them a check let's say i've brought them
let's say sorry they borrowed me um 50
bags he will send them a check of 100
bags obviously their guests are oh my
god thank you so much yada yada these
men are checking their account every
single day
never arriving every single day one
night was bailing on the phone like i've
got bills to pay i don't know what i'm
gonna do
i don't know what i'm gonna do
he ruins lives
he does he does he does
man has no care in the world he went
penn for this night went pen i think he
was meant to go in for 15 months he
stayed in for four or five came out
he's probably had a better valentine's
day than we did
wow you know what i mean man just said
my enemies my enemies my enemies my
enemies they're signing checks bro
they just gave the money away i'm
telling you for a fact yeah for a fact
no buffing could fly me out to anywhere
tease me for a month
and then when i get back to yard yeah
and i'm in my cubicle my nine to five
say james my enemies this and that i
need you to to run to the bank and draws
out a young 10 bags
put your remortgage your yard do
whatever it takes i'd be thinking who
does she think she is
100 fam use your contacts a lie don't
chat to me about it so what are your
cars
don't talk to me about it
your enemies are your enemies bro
i'm sorry that it had to be you
i really am
summer was fantastic
thank you for sam i hadn't lived like
that before you've shown me things
you've shown me things that i thought
i'd never see
but it ends here
because
if i could afford that lifestyle then
you can have your ten back exactly but
clearly i got 10 bags no bomb bro sell
your car re-mortgage your yard whatever
you need to do saying the most he was
saying the most what's the end game here
family just keeps on doing it over and
over and over what man got out of penang
was doing the same thing the next day
he's got a girl rate him he's got a girl
he's got whips this that and the other
he was taking a [ __ ] out on a
helicopter family he's come out a pen
he's come out a pen for swindling hoes
he's worldwide and yes is still dating
him
from
it perplexed me bro humans just feel
special they do they do that yes of
course yes they do but i feel like it's
also one of those ones where like i said
for example
because he ropes you in for that first
month
and
he he makes it seem as if you are
literally the only girl in the world oh
i bet and but on a different scale i bet
on a different scale james he they first
swiped for this one of the first chick i
can't remember the actual names let's
call uh let's call it helen
helen swiped um for him for my man they
were talking talking talking for a
little bit and he said uh meet me out
here for coffee i use telly for a coffee
because i'm i'm flying to x tomorrow
they met up for a coffee blah blah blah
and he was like
this is weird but you want to go to for
example geneva tomorrow
let's continue this
ghast of course she's never been on a
jet before none look you're injured of
course you're dead
they go to geneva now he's got a u with
another chick we don't even know how
that pattern blah blah blah they're
flying out she's back they're back and
forth back and forth back and forth
dinner here restaurant there all of this
stuff clubs cars the works
yachts seafood everywhere bro she comes
back now comes back to reality
they're dating now
a few months down the line they want to
move in with each other because that's
how close they are wow that's how close
she sucked he sucked her in
moving this thing these times she's
looking for apartments in let's say
um france for example my man's in
germany for example doing business my
man's got his next thing while she's
looking for yards in germany he's doing
now in france yeah he's coming up
germany
with a german team while she's looking
for yards in france we're back in geneva
we're back we're doing the whole loop
bro it's nuts
that's why i need i need to understand
the roi bro how much has he got left at
the end of this he the thing is man when
man went from sky high he was broke in
three weeks when they like when these
when the two yats did what they needed
to do
to shame and name and shame him yeah
yeah man was man was a different man i
heard the voice notes i heard the voice
notes
you see he called himself the homeless
king
i have a homeless a homeless king bro
man in one picture here he man's all
like a million bucks
clean shaven next picture baggy tea
moustache bed hair all over the place
slim
homeless kid that's what he called
himself brother it was nuts
it was nuts
man went to pen after that came back out
and still does the same thing you see
videos of him like closing the ferrari
door getting opening the door for his
girl blah blah blah oh that's all long
it's nuts to me
nuts to me it was a good watch don't get
me wrong sounds like a watch but it's
just like
wow